plans are in full swing for dancing
stars Val and Jetta
but vows well ladies to work as
Telemundo's Francisco Chris Harris found
out we are writing on what I say why
that's not please maybe they may need to
get on the same page before their
upcoming I Do's as for the rest of the
wedding details while Jennifer got it
handled her easiest decision the dress
went in and I knew what I wanted so yeah
it was the first one and it was like I
know this is it have you decided on your
song for the first dance
oh yeah Livia Murcia Oh Oh perfect
I think a lot of people expect us to do
a big choreographed dance and we're just
gonna plugged in on the guest list valid
Jenna's past dancing partners including
Laurie Hernandez former Willis and the
bachelorettes grocery store Joe Adam rip
on as Jenna's bride's man Val's brother
Max is his best man and nephews I will
also be a part of the ceremony and only
we were with the couple for their cake
tasting this is the banana chocolate
chip spicy carrot fleur de sel this is
enough chocolate hazelnut and vanilla
bean
we're gonna have one of each of the five
of them or five Cheers flavor for
everyone
bunny for everyone and they could do
that they just dance it off all right
well you heard Jenna talk about finding
her wedding gown it was all captured on
camera for an upcoming episode of say
yes to the dress on TLC
[Music]
[Applause]